[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy sunday it's a great day for
football we are five days away from
thanksgiving so we're about to go from
beast mode to
feast mode welcome to the squad ride
live on the bleacher report app
brought to you by draftkings my name is
cabby richards the young lady in the
middle is the big bang
our betting expert kelly stewart and the
homie on the far right
is the wizard of winners only wednesday
greg ivory
good morning this is the show where we
bet anytime touchdowns chosen by you
the squad let's get rich we're seven and
three on the season and
salute to riley sorbo and his chameleon
for the devonta adams last week
uh devonta's pick last week we got to
send that chameleon some fried cheese
curds
from wisconsin for being such a good boy
or girl
okay anyway a few days ago we asked you
on social to drop your pick to score a
touchdown this week
these are the most popular picks you
sent us let's go to the board
we got some great talent up here ezekiel
elliott is back in the mix of playing
cowboys are playing minnesota mike evans
against the chargers today
we have a taysom hill signing playing
quarterback or tight end depending on
your fantasy league
against the atlanta falcons we have five
legendary videos to show you which will
decide
our week 11 squad ride the confidence
ran higher than nick chubb with a wide
open field
of last week here are some of our
favorite videos
from you hey you want to win some money
i'm going to tell you why antonio brown
is going to score a touchdown this
sunday
plus 200 we're riding with cam newton
travis holden is a lot
i'm locking in miles sanders scoring a
touchdown that boy
is dangerous he's a god nick chubb any
time to score
is a lock what do you think bud i'm
gonna bet this great
i'm gonna bet this break until the
streak doesn't hit anymore so that's it
take your money put it all tb to a b
this week winners
only please i'll take that all
night long
greg will be giving away hoodies all
day long the snapchat filter is back uh
hey listen
as long as you fire off hot takes in the
comments or
drop winners only please
g-money will you please please that's
right hey you about to tap in with the
commenters g-money
gabby you see you see i have it in my
hand okay
i have it in my hand and you're telling
me it's time it's time to tap in
i have my handy dandy ipad right here
i'm
in the comments looking for takes i got
uh
madeleine madeleine saying keenan allen
td
and t higgins td 100 you are
walking away with a hoodie because both
of those guys are on my fantasy team
so uh you're walking away with a hoodie
i got um
nevertheless craig's never biased
p-s-p-i-e-l-9
he's saying dalvin cook all day he's
been
hot lately i'm loving this take cabbie
loving this take he wants a sweatshirt
you're walking away with a hoodie
brother
uh i'm gonna oh he also dropped some
winners only please hashtag yes yes yes
you guys know that's what i like
cabbie i'm done in the comments i'm done
i'm done for right now
i'm done let's get on with the show and
i'll be back in here soon let's go so
for those who are watching this for the
first time the way this tournament works
is videos face off against each other
and the audience you chooses which video
will move and player will move on to the
next round so let's begin round one
two weeks ago it was chickens last week
a chameleon took us by storm our first
pitch
comes from the defending squad ride
champion riley sorbo
riley which member of the animal kingdom
do you have locking in to touch that
this week
squad ride pick them oh my god
the assassination game
lock in your picks baby
rango is back i don't know if you guys
remember that movie but very similar
chameleons um okay we're still waiting
to see if um
the chameleon gets 15 office insurance
but we're gonna find
out very soon uh his next opponent is
eric friedman
and his homie reggie chopping it up
anytime touchdown score featuring reggie
we got taysom hill
cam newton lamar jackson and deshawn
[Music]
watson
reggie reggie i hope you get the biggest
piece of cheese for that okay so our
first two pitches are in
nick chubb and cam newton tell us in the
comments who should move on
uh g-money what do you think of animal
crossing making an appearance in the
squad ride this week
calves calves caps it's so
easy a chameleon can do it i mean i
thought this i thought he was a gecko
last week
he's a chameleon but i let's talk about
the execution of the video they slowed
it down for us
we were able to see what he actually
captured they slowed it down for us
um i mean he he was the this this lizard
chameleon uh gecko whatever it is it was
eating cheese last week
this week it's using his tongue to catch
a worm i mean
it seems like it understands
what it means to level up and here for
the squad wide we ask you guys
to level up when you send these videos
let's talk about the pick though kelly
let's talk about the pick
uh i got nick chubb facing um
they're facing philly today nick chubb
saying that one minus 115 facing philly
it's not too bad
let's talk about the other video cabbie
i mean this rat is obviously a genius
it should probably be in the science lab
somewhere uh
hearing diseases i mean it's a genius uh
i'm glad i'm i'm glad that we have it
here to
help us decide um the pick
but uh kelly talk to me please talk to
me or cabbie you can talk to me too
we have nick chubb we have cam newton
nick chubb is facing philadelphia cam
newton is facing that
houston texans defense
talk to me what are your thoughts where
are we thinking where are we riding
uh kelly talk to me cabbie talk to me
whoever i just need somebody to tell me
what are your thoughts greg
listen i i think we got some camera
issues i don't know why now you guys can
all tell i'm party on top sweatpants on
the bottom it's sunday morning
i don't know if you guys can hear me at
all because i'm not on camera
but let me tell you what i'm seeing with
nick chubb
i'm going to do the greg thing i'm going
to be biased here i have kareem hunt
on my fantasy team so absolutely not do
i want
chubb to score a touchdown but i want
you guys to be wary here
now look the browns have been a three
point favorite it seems like almost
every week this year in the nfl
now this moves from three to two and a
half i'm not saying bet the eagles i'm
saying be
cautious here the bookmakers are showing
their hand and they want you to bet the
browns
on the flip side i'm all about
cam newton scoring a touchdown against
well frankly
not that good of kind of a shell of its
former self
in terms of at houston texans defense
i know that i put the houston texans in
a teaser this week i do
think desean watson and cam newton are
both going to have themselves a day
but if i have to pick between nick chubb
and cam newton
i'm going to take cam newton here to
score a touchdown and oh by the way i'm
loving these animal videos keep them
coming i'm loving them
oh macdonald had a pond
so g-money how is the audience reacting
to um
to the the gecko or i mean the chameleon
or the rat
or the you know the browns and the
eagles the texans and the patriots
where where's everybody at
you know what this is cavi handy danny
ipad i'm
in the comments looking i'm looking
cabbie they're back and forth
uh they're back and forth they're back
and forth in the comments some guy
lachey is talking about miles sanders
scoring today
uh lashay i love the take you're walking
away with a hoodie but let's talk about
chubb or newton i got riles232
says chubb and hunt are going to eat in
bad weather
games so uh they have they have the
inside scoop of cour
apparently it's going to be a bad
weather game rouse 2 232 you're walking
away with a hoodie
um i got k rup 24 chameleon legend for
sure nick chubb and kareem hunt
are both scoring today eagles run
defense can't stop
anything brown's running backs are going
to be running
for days cabbie uh it's back and forth
okay the next one the next one i'm gonna
i'm gonna decide here
here captain uh here we go
here we go i got um
i got d style saying what's going on do
you know who that man newton is
fire fire fire d style you're walking
away
with the hoodie cabbie the people have
chosen we're walking we're running we're
running with cam newton and the rat
legend moving on
okay for the next round hey i didn't
think it was gonna turn like that but
there we go
the audience decides eric friedman and
the rat legend
cam newton winner of round one moving on
to round two
but you know how this game works you
need to win three more times
to become the squad ride leader round
two let's get it our next pitch
comes from mike oc and another furry
friend
wow okay nice and quiet there's no like
it was a very serene scene okay you have
the rat
you've heard from the squirrel this is
our first qb matchup ever with
with cam newton versus lamar jackson who
coincidentally faced off last week
in a monsoon in foxborough but tell us
in the comments
who should move on to round three this
is our round two matchup these two
quarterbacks
g-money what'd you think about this
latest pick with the squirrel legend
the rat legend was impressive cabbie but
that thing
is domesticated a squirrel is basically
a wild rat
like and this guy got the squirrel to
participate and not only participate
but pick lamar jackson at plus 120.
like i'm sold on this like i want to put
this in literally
right now like i'm i'm sold on this
cabbie
kelly um while i put this into my phone
i need you to talk to me lamar jackson
plus one tony
cam newton facing that houston texas
defense
talk to me uh i'm gonna look this one up
right now
there's a couple of ways you can look at
this and this is what scares me about
lamar jackson i think what we saw last
week
is defensive-minded coaches like bill
belichick have figured
my dude out i love lamar jackson i even
have an ode to him on my planner i think
he is one of the hardest working guys in
the league
the problem is when you are limited to
throwing right and passing left
and rushing up the middle they're gonna
figure you out in the nfl and i hope
that's not the case but i do feel like
it is
coupled with the fact that the ravens
have the steelers
on thanksgiving day i think this is
gonna be a close game with the titans
i took the titans plus six lamar to
score a touchdown
maybe but if i have to pick and choose
i'm going to take cam newton
all day all right all right
g money how's the audience reacting
gabby yes sir back into the comments
it's back and forth
it's it's always back and forth in the
comments i got a champ 2126
jackson is to have a bounce back game
the squirrel gods knows
what's up uh cabbie uh
i got jimmy woods eight sang lamar
jackson lamar jackson lamar jackson
jimmy woods you're walking away with a
hoodie
uh next one next one we're riding with
all right cabby next one we are riding
with
uh i got max rexel lamar got humiliated
last week
uh coming back strong this week he has
the faith
in lamar jackson he also has the faith
in the squirrel legend and uh i'm riding
i'm making the choice right here i'm
riding with lamar jackson
uh so lamar jackson and the squirrel
legend cabbie is moving on
to the next round if you're riding with
the squirrel legend that means we are
riding with the squirrel legend
so thank you to mike oc for
domesticating a squirrel which is
very very impressive and we're going and
we are rocking with
the current mvp in round two that's
lamar jackson two more rounds to go
before we anoint a squad ride leader
let's get to round three next up is
blake song one
who do you have locked in to score a
touchdown this one
so i've been working on this new
software that's hopefully gonna help me
start winning some of my bets
i don't know if you guys will be able to
understand all this but you know running
some numbers and uh
should be able to calculate who's going
to score a touchdown this week
honestly i'm kind of new to coding so
i'm not sure if it's going to work but
let's give it a try who's going to score
a touchdown this week
this week todd gurley is going to rush
for a touchdown against the saints
my man's arthritis is located after the
bye week
he will be putting in that work on the
ground
speaking of running backs lamar jackson
will rush for a touchdown against
tennessee
i have ran the numbers and it's a lock
big trust
big trust big trust
blake's algorithm we're so strong it
tried to give us two picks but we're
gonna go with the first one
with todd gurley uh greg how does this
how does this pick
process with your own algorithm
cabbie i mean you know we have meetings
production means we're always talking
about
algorithms here but this guy he legit
has an algorithm i mean it even talks
back to him like that's kind of scary
like
that's really kind of scary but i do
know you and your computer
wednesdays tap into winners only
wednesdays we gonna get you in your
computer
your algorithms on the live i mean why
not but let's talk about the pick cabbie
and kelly
let's talk about the pick todd gurley
sitting at -125 he's facing
new orleans uh today uh
what are you thinking kelly we got lamar
jackson
todd gurley uh give me something give me
something here
you know i really went back and forth on
this game i'll be honest with you
uh with taysom hill getting named as a
starting quarterback i had
visions of going sean payton what the
hell are you thinking how do you not go
with my dude jameis winston
we're gonna find out maybe he knows more
than me so i didn't play a side here
but i think this is going to be a high
scoring affair every time these
divisional rivals get together it's
points of plenty i think todd gurley's
going to score touchdown i think julio
jones is going to score a touchdown
payson phil maybe
even does a quarterback keeper so look
for the over in this one and
sure i'll go with todd gurley to score a
td oh nice i mean we had we had taysom
hill at the be uh at the beginning plus
150 i believe on draftkings to score a
touchdown
gonna be a very interesting game and
gamesmanship on that sunday
that divisional matchup g-money where is
the audience leaning are they leaning
lamar jackson or sorry lamar jackson
todd gurley
whoever what do we got my dude
cabbie i'm in the comments i'm in the
comments giving away hoodies
uh j d j digas
85 says girly for sure
he's adamant about that he's rocking
with ty gurley you're walking away with
a hoodie
h2 h2 cabbie but he spells it
h-t-w-o little creative right there
h2 tg 3000 for the score i'mma say
two tds he's also
rocking with todd gurley and thinks that
he's going to score two tds oh my gosh
i got one more for you cabbie i got one
more for you cabbie
s-k-h-o-w-e-s-s-a i'll spell it out for
our producers
big trust know what's up girly get it in
breeze less saints the breezeless saints
girly's getting it in cabbie it's it's
it's it's
i mean it's as clear as day we're
rocking with todd gurley
in the algorithm legend moving on to the
next round
well done blake song uh please let us
know if you can give us some other tips
moving forward
the algorithm legend selects todd gurley
in round three
that's who we're moving on with to the
final round so three quarters down
this is the final matchup todd gurley
versus whoever wins this matchup is our
squad ride leader
let's get to it our final pitch comes
from silly man
who sees things clear
man i can't keep betting the cowboys
money lying and
zeke just ain't what he used to be i
don't know what to do
i'm down bad betting guys if you hear me
send me a sign
[Music]
okay climb to the highest peak and you
will find the lock you seek
[Music]
uh that was incredible uh tell us in the
comments
whether you're riding with the algorithm
and todd gurley
or the vision quest and aaron jones of
the green bay packers
uh greg what did you think of our final
pitch and the heights
that silly man went to to get this pick
kathy i'm over here just mesmerized
because like we've seen a lot of
cinematic
content on the show people sent it in
all the time but this one takes the cake
let me tell you why
multiple locations a cameo from
god himself special effects
and the way just the way the
just the way the the the pig just you
know
uh ran across the sky it just seemed
yeah it just appeared it appeared like
a lock it appeared like a winner's only
please
cabbie so uh i'm loving this and jones
sitting at a minus 139
is not a bad play kelly i need you to
talk to me
we got jones sitting at minus 139 we got
gurley minus 125.
uh give me some thoughts kelly i'm gonna
give you my thoughts when it comes to my
best bet here
in a minute but i need to go with silly
man because
i need the gambling gods on my side my
best bets have been absolutely atrocious
this year what happened
last year it was so money this year has
just been
rough we'll get to that here in a minute
if i have to choose between these two
i'm gonna take todd gurley to score as i
mentioned i like that to be a high
scoring affair
and uh i think that colts defense will
shut down
the packers running game forcing aaron
rodgers to have to throw the ball so
we're gonna go with todd gurley here the
sun shining through my window maybe the
gambling gods
are giving me a sign all right so let us
know in the comments if you're rocking
with
todd gurley or aaron jones vote for our
winner
to name the squad ride in week 11. as
you mentioned kelly
aaron rodgers you know he's got that
hail mary
uh capability from the gambling gods
gambling gods do you hear us
get on draftkings lock in your picks
ladies and gentlemen okay while you do
that
our mvp kelly stewart as she mentioned
she teased
her best bet now kelly give it to us
in week 11 who are you locking in
as i mentioned we got the sun shining
through this window i feel
the aura i feel really good about this
best fat mainly
because our boss started giving me two
days off so i got way more time
to focus on these games than i have in
the past so
i spent a lot of time this week on this
one and i went with the colts money line
now
the reason why i went with moneyline
instead of one and a half or two and a
half is because
the books are receiving a ton of packers
money line
thus the money line doesn't really
correlate with the one and a half and
yes
nfl games do land one contrary to
popular belief we've seen it happen at
least a dozen times this year and it's
going to continue to happen now that
we've seen the extra point moved
back that being said i'm going to take
the better defense here
at home this colts team is able to
stifle quarterbacks and we've seen them
do it week in
and week out particularly when they can
stop the run
last thursday we saw the colts in the
second half against the titans be able
to stop the run if you do that you take
quarterbacks out of their game
aaron jones is going to be stifled this
week forcing aaron rodgers to make
big plays the problem is aaron rodgers
no longer has guys like jordy nelson
randall cobb he's only got one weapon in
devonta adams sure
beldas scantlane every once in a while
comes to play
but it's not going to happen today
colt's on the money line colts win big
just like we saw with that tampa bay
defense we will see it this week with
that colts defense let's go cold
okay lock it in get on draftkings 63
colts versus the seven and two packers
will be an awesome game thank you very
much to our mvp kelly stewart
hopefully the gambling gods are
listening to us on in week 11.
greg aubry it's that time in the show
where the decision has already been made
by the audience
but now tell us please who are we riding
riding with as our squad ride in week
11. and my guy
drew mccarty 11. he says aaron jones
doesn't just put up one td
cabbie he puts up two dude is an
absolute beast when he's healthy
i want my hoodie big truss guess what
drew you're walking away with a hoodie
brother
because i love that take let me give you
another take cabbie
uh shimmy burger says jones is gonna
score today
i will get a hoodie today so greg i'm
waiting for that hoodie
where's where's that hoodie where the
hoodie got greg i know you see this on
the handy dandy ipad
brother do you see what this is this is
the handy dandy ipad and i saw that
shimmy burger you're also walking away
what are you cabbie i'm calling it i'm
calling it i don't need to read anymore
i'm calling it you're calling
aaron jones let's get it aaron jones
where's the graphic where's the graphic
i need the graphic aaron jones you see
it right there it's in the green at -139
it just flipped you guys see it plus 300
we're rocking with aaron jones
uh for the squad ride today right after
the show
we're gonna go we're gonna we're gonna
keep this squad ride going right on the
br
ig story make sure you guys send me all
your videos
send them to me uh but please but please
but please
remember
cabbie i'm not gonna say it i want them
to say it in the comments you guys said
in the comments i'm gonna give away some
hoodies
how about that that's a nice little
tease right there how about that as greg
mentioned
follow us our br betting on social on
either instagram or twitter
to get the link for the odds boost from
our friends at draftkings that's very
important
send us the screenshots of your winners
or your tickets
before the games that's also important
because we want to celebrate
victories with you uh let's get rich on
a football sunday
because we want winners listen uh good
luck with your wagers
um tap in with br greg on the instagram
story on br
betting on ig because that's very fun a
great way to follow along the action
congrats to all our hoodie winners and
gabby
wait cabbie cabbie wait caddy wait
please wait wait wait i see a lot of
comments go watch
football here we go g-money
g-money winners only greg you're walking
away with a hoodie
i got b-tab 24 winners only please
you're also walking away with a hoodie
mpav winter zone you're walking away
with a hoodie eric win
you're winning today you're walking away
with a hoodie crying
g-money you're walking away with a
hoodie cabbie the people
they have spoken winners only please
send them to me please after this
captain's cutting me off he's cutting me
off guys right now
he's like you're about to get fired from
a job and you just give away the house
that's what he's doing what
greg are you leaving like what's going
on here hey hey kelly i'm just giving
the people what they want
cabbie's cutting me off you guys i need
caps in the comments for captain i'm
just kidding
it's only thanksgiving it's not quite
christmas yet so
we gotta see we gotta hang on some
hoodies but we appreciate everybody who
tapped in
who commented who had some fire takes
and the dope
thank you to our legends this week riley
sorbo eric friedman
uh mike o'shea blake's song and his
algorithm
and then the silly man gambling guys
hope you're rocking with us
thank you very much for joining us
alongside kelly stewart greg ivory my
name is cabbie richards you're watching
the squad ride and good luck peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you